But the problem that plagues the health care system is not just a problem for the uninsured.
Those who do have insurance have never had less security and stability than they do today.
More and more Americans worry that if you move, lose your job or change your job,...
...you'll lose your health insurance too.
More and more Americans pay their premiums...
...only to discover that their insurance company has dropped their coverage when they get sick...
...or won't pay the full cost of care.
It happens every day.
One man from Illinois lost his coverage in the middle of chemotherapy...
...because his insurer found that he hadn't reported gallstones that he didn't even know about.
They delayed his treatment...
...and he died because of it.
Another woman from Texas was about to get a double mastectomy...
...when her insurance company canceled her policy because she forgot to declare a case of acne.
By the time she had her insurance reinstated,...
...her breast cancer had more than doubled in size.
That is heartbreaking.
It is wrong...
...and no one should be treated that way in the United States of America.